the Earth is a gigantic ball of
semi-molton Rock with a heart of iron as
hot as the surface of the Sun Titanic
amounts of heat left over from its birth
and the radioactive decay of trillions
of tons of radioactive elements find No
Escape but up currents of rock spanning
thousands of kilometers carry this
energy to the surface
Earth's crust is the only thing in their
way it feels solid to us but it's only a
fragile barrier an apple skin around a
flaming behemoth
true apocalypses can break through and
unleash eruptions tens of times more
powerful than all of our nuclear weapons
combined subjecting the climate to
centuries worth of change in a single
year while drowning continents in toxic
Ash and gases
super volcanoes
how big can they get and will they put
an end to humanity
[Music]
volcanoes
there are many types of volcanoes from
towering mountains to lava domes but
they have two main sources the first is
that the boundaries between tectonic
plates the pieces of the crust that
cover the Earth like a giant jigsaw
puzzle there are seven major tectonic
plates and dozens of smaller ones
drifting against each other at up to 15
centimeters per year this sounds slow
but on geological time scales it is a
Titanic struggle over who gets to stay
on the surface the winning plate
crumples into a new mountain range while
the loser is shoved underneath into an
ocean of hot rock at 1 300 degrees
Celsius the asthenosphere
the temperature here is enough to melt
rock into a liquid but the insane
pressures of all that mass keep it a
superheated sonnet tectonic plates are
usually in contact with water for
thousands of years and absorb some of it
when they're submerged into the hot
underworld this water triggers chemical
Transformations that allow tiny portions
to melt into magma
liquid magma is less dense than Solid
Rock so it rises to the surface in
Furious bubbles that accumulate in
sponge-like reservoirs right under the
crust if enough magma accumulates it
becomes powerful enough to pierce
through the crust which we experience as
volcanoes
this happens under the winning plate
like a Revenge attack by the loser
before it's erased forever
the second main source of volcanoes are
thought to be mantle plumes these are
columns of abnormally hot rock that rise
all the way from the planet's core
mantle boundary to the surface much less
is known about them but in a way it's as
if the Earth's mantle has weather
patterns and mantle plumes are a little
like hot air rising to form storm clouds
storms hundreds of millions of years old
made of rocks circulating at a rate of a
few millimeters per month
they don't care about the motion of
tectonic plates so they can break the
crust to create volcanoes in the middle
of nowhere that stubbornly stay active
as the crust shifts around them
the volcanic boom meter
scientists love to put big booms on a
scale and came up with a logarithmic
scale that measures the volume ejected
during an eruption the volcanic
explosivity index or vei simply put it
starts really small and gets very big
very quickly
a vei 2 eruption would fill 400 full
Olympic swimming pools with lava we have
around 10 of these per year
at vei 3 we already see devastating
effects like the eruption of the semaru
volcano in 2021 that destroyed thousands
of homes in Indonesia
at vei 5 we see catastrophic amounts of
materials cubic kilometers of debris
equivalent to an entire Lake of molten
rock blasted into the air like the 2022
hunger Tonga hunger hapai eruption that
sent a Shockwave around the globe many
times and created ocean-wide tsunamis
at a vei of six an eruption can change
the world in 1883 the Indonesian island
volcano Krakatoa erupted nearly
continuously over the course of five
months one of those eruptions blew it
apart producing the loudest sound
recorded in history 10 trillion times
louder than a Rocket taking off heard
Halfway Around the World
30 meter high tsunamis Swept Away nearby
populations and so much gas and Ash were
released the global temperatures cooled
by nearly 0.5 degrees Celsius
red Dusty sunsets followed for many
years
at vei7 we get super colossal eruptions
Millennium defining events that human
civilization has only encountered a
handful of times
Mount Tambora was a 4 300 meter high
mountain until it exploded in 1815 and
released 400 times more energy than the
Tsar bomber
140 billion tons of Ash and dust were
shot halfway to space before smothering
the world's skies turning them a sickly
yellow
there was no summer the following year
crops died and over a hundred thousand
people perished
this is the Dreadful potential of
volcanic eruptions with famines across
the other side of the world and even
centuries-long cold periods being
attributed to them
okay but what's a super volcano
the term supervolcano is a media
invention and not a scientific term the
main issue with them is that not every
eruption from a super volcano is a super
eruption
what makes super volcanoes special is
that they've been waiting to erupt for
hundreds of thousands of years
pressure builds up in colossal magma
reservoirs several kilometers deep until
it becomes strong enough to lift the
rock Above It by several meters rocks
crack under the pressure until they
finally give way and billions of tons of
gas and Ash blast out at supersonic
speed an insane explosion of at least a
thousand cubic kilometers that impacts
every corner of the globe and yet that
is only a small portion of the magma
Reservoir
super eruptions are like a Boiling Pot
of water popping its lid off and
spitting a bit off the top afterwards
the ground collapses into the void Left
Behind forming a hole called a Caldera
under this Caldera precious dance
building again until the volcano gathers
enough energy for another Super eruption
but this could take hundreds of
thousands of years
it's estimated that one of the few
volcanoes capable of super eruptions on
Earth could cause a catastrophic
eruption every 17 000 years on average
that would make them far more frequent
than comparable asteroid impacts the
most recent super eruption is the orenui
eruption 26 500 years ago in New Zealand
with the force of dozens of billions of
tons of TNT a mount everest-sized pile
of explosives a huge portion of the
landscape was scooped out and thrown
into the atmosphere
it left behind a Caldera spanning 20
kilometers and it caused the entire
southern hemisphere to undergo a period
of abrupt Cooling though among super
eruptions it's a mere firework
the lake tuber eruption of 74 000 years
ago was a much more significant turning
point in history it released a
gargantuan 5 300 cubic kilometers of
material enough to blanket parts of
South Asia in 15 centimeters of Ash and
trigger a rapid 4 degrees Celsius drop
in global temperatures
it's possible that the volcanic winter
lasted 10 years followed by worldwide
droughts for centuries
earth's climate might have not recovered
for a thousand years
the largest volcanic events we know of
were not really huge explosions but
floods of millions of cubic kilometers
of lava the grand finale were the
Siberian traps around 250 million years
ago a continuous release of lava for two
million years
they raised the ocean temperatures to
over 40 degrees celsius which caused the
Permian Triassic Extinction killing over
90 percent of all species
Earth's surface needed 9 million years
to recover
sorts of eruptions don't change the
climate they are the climate
but thankfully we haven't seen anything
even remotely close to that scale in
many millions of years
so should you be scared of super
volcanoes
definitely not they've been used to
frighten many people and are overhyped
as an unavoidable apocalypse the most
famous One Yellowstone will erupt again
but they will be relatively smaller
options
natural disasters for sure but not
enough to devastate the U.S or come
close to ending Humanity
chance of a ve I8 eruption in the next
few hundred years is less than two
percent and more importantly it wouldn't
come as a sudden surprise
however less powerful but more frequent
eruptions can also do serious damage to
our civilizations and are in many ways a
much greater concern
so we must watch for slow changes in
magma reservoirs like ground swelling
and temperature increases to get an
early warning that can save the lives of
people living the closest to a volcano
and there's time to develop solutions
that can remove sulfur and Ash from the
stratosphere to eliminate the root cause
of the climate disruption we've seen
from previous eruptions
who knows maybe we'll even be able to
turn this force of Destruction into an
agent for Good by exploiting the
geothermal energy held in their giant
magma reservoirs
we've done this work for so many other
disasters and we are already doing
things we could only have dreamed about
decades ago like sending a probe to
perform our first asteroid redirection
test with determination Humanity ready
can solve anything
so while deep below us an angry hell is
churning and waiting for its moment you
can sleep well tonight
learning how we can get ahead of
catastrophes like climate change and
super volcanoes is interesting but can
also be challenging maybe you still feel
like you don't really understand how
most of the science behind it works and
on your own it seems too hard to dig
deeper to solve this we've collaborated
with our friends from brilliant to
create a series of lessons to build your
understanding of fundamental science by
exploring fascinating insights from our
most popular videos on topics like black
holes the size of life and climate
change brilliant is an Interactive
Learning tool that makes science
accessible with a Hands-On approach
because we know that to really learn
something you've got to do it think of
each lesson as a one-on-one Deep dive
version of a quartz gazard video in our
latest lessons you'll discover the
mechanisms that drive climate change and
use them to understand the impact of
supervolcanoes on our global climate
Beyond new koskazard lessons regularly
released brilliant has thousands of
lessons for members to explore from
maths-based topics like algebra and
probability to the concepts behind
machine learning and Quantum Computing
with new releases each month you'll
always find something fascinating to
learn to get Hands-On with cuts exact
lessons now go to brilliant.org Nutshell
and sign up for free and with a free
trial of brilliant premium you can
explore everything brilliant has to
offer there's even an extra perk for
courts because our viewers the first 200
people to use the link get 20 off their
annual membership which unlocks all of
brilliant's courses in maths science and
computer science we love going down a
rabbit hole with our research brilliant
will take you by the hand to come along
on the ride
foreign
[Music]
[Music]